hi everyone its Ilana and today I'm
going to be talking to you guys about my
problem with BioShock Infinite so a lot
of people said last year that BioShock
Infinite was their game of the year I
had one of the best plots in any video
game and they've never been that blown
away and that's where my problem starts
here BioShock Infinite is what I would
call hyper violent majority of what you
do in this game is kill people so my
first issue here is that there are two
separate stories happening and there's
such a huge disconnect there there's
this one story which is what your
character booker dewitt is actually
going through that's what you do for
most of the game is fight the actual
storyline of BioShock Infinite isn't get
whisked into giant sky city find go
discover truth it's actually fight a
bunch of bad guys in a city little
snippets of other plot points
occasionally happen and then there's
this other stories where every now and
then there's an audio file or a cutscene
that tells you about this completely
different thing so this is to massively
different sequences happening and they
try to tell you that you should be
invested in the other one the one that
you don't spend most of your time doing
in the game so I felt this huge
disconnect but I also had a massive
issue with the combat feeling extremely
unnecessary as a result of this I guess
this only really came to light with me
when I played burial at sea the burial
at sea only goes for about four hours
and the actual plot in burial at sea is
almost equally as satisfying as the plot
in the entirety of BioShock Infinite
so I sat down I was like okay what did I
do in the other 10 hours of BioShock
Infinite when I wasn't being strung
along by a plot all you actually do in
that game is loot and shoot but when it
comes down to it Bioshock is a shooter
the difference between this and
cheaters is that it acts like it's not a
shooter where a lot of shooters have
stories about shooting tech halo for
example you are literally a guy trying
to fight a war to save a planet and if
you don't kill these people that the
halo will go off and everyone's gonna
die BioShock Infinite you're this guy
who has no idea what's going on and
everyone just happens to be shooting at
you it's inconsistent and it's
incoherent and it's frustrating and it
ruins the experience while I won't deny
that the game beautifully breadcrumbed
along all these little secrets to try
and unfold what was going to happen at
the end getting there was filled with so
much noise that for me it really really
distorted that game I guess I'm doing
one thing that a reviewer should never
do this isn't a review so it's okay
right and I'm being sad that this game
wasn't the game that it could have been
and instead it was a shooter and that
didn't make sense but thank you guys for
watching those are just my thoughts and
I will see you all next time bye